[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend in einen mit
superlativen sollte man vorsichtig sein
sagte der große hans joachim friedrichs
gerade als nachrichtenmoderator aber im
vereinigten königreich sprechen sie
heute von historisch von einem
historischen wahlsieg
erstmals in der geschichte nordirlands
ist die katholisch republikanische
partei sinn fein stärkste kraft im
parlament
schimpfen das waren mal die die als
politischer arm der ira galten
politische vertretung von denen also die
gebombt haben und getötet um ihr ziel zu
erreichen die loslösung von
großbritannien die vereinigung mit der
republik irland
diese einheit steht jetzt nicht sofort
an sie ist heute aber ein stück näher
gerückt andreas stamm
geboren aus der gewalt als politischer
arm der ira aus einem blutigen
bürgerkrieg gegen die britische armee
gegen die paramilitärs der unionisten
ein weiter weg für schimpfen lange
undenkbar nun stellen sie 100 jahre
nordirische geschichte auf den kopf ein
jubelmeer die partei die sich die
vereinigung mit der republik irland auf
die fahnen geschrieben hat stärkste
kraft im parlament
ich bestärke alle die die vereinigung
noch nicht sehen lasst uns reden eine
sachliche debatte darüber führen wir
unsere zukunft aussehen soll mit dabei
die parteivorsitzende die weiß wie viel
unruhe das ergebnis bringt
habt keine angst erklärt sie nur kein
triumphgeheul denn um die
regierungschefin zu stellen braucht es
die zustimmung der größten
unionistenpartei die op eine
besonderheit teil des friedensabkommens
von 98 doch den unionisten steht die
angst im gesicht hatten vor der wahl
schon angekündigt lieber keine regierung
lieber ein politisches vakuum als
juniorpartner von schimpfen weil das
ihren größten albtraum näher bringen
könnte nordirland nicht mehr britisch
sondern irisch
man könnte auch bei den wahlen in irland
stärkste kraft werden dann in beiden
teilen der irischen insel das wäre ein
deutlicher schritt richtung vereinigung
aber die britische regierung mit einer
volksabstimmung darüber erst zustimmen
wenn sich eine mehrheit für die
vereinigung abzeichnet und die gibt es
noch nicht
weiterer streitpunkt nordirland
sonderstatus nach dem break sieht es ist
teil des eu binnenmarkt geblieben so
soll eine grenze zu irland ein mögliches
wieder aufflammen von gewalt verhindert
werden die unionisten wollen den
sonderstatus abschaffen er bedrohe die
identität der probritischen nordiren
befördere wirtschaftlich den weg
richtung vereinigung auch hier hat der
wähler gesprochen eine mehrheit im neuen
parlament ist gegen eine neuverhandlung
mit der eu damit ist das wahlergebnis
auch eine niederlage für die britische
regierung die brüssel seit monaten mit
dem bruch des brh exit vertrags droht
doch langfristig droht er anbruch des
vereinigten königreichs davos nordloh
mehrheit hat in nordirland gegen den
dreck sitzer stimmt england wollte ihn
und hat sich damit auf einen anderen
historischen weg gegeben dazu die
demographie die pro irischen katholiken
werden mehr die zahl der probritischen
protestanten nimmt ab ich bin selbst pro
britisch und sage wie viele warum das
unvermeidliche herauszögern
der weg von den fehlern die politische
spitze war lang doch bei allem jubel bis
zu deren ziel der friedlichen
vereinigung mit irland ist es ebenfalls
noch ein weiter weg
alle frauen alle kindern und alle
älteren menschen sind jetzt evakuiert
aus dem belagerten stahlwerk in mario
pohl raus aus einer situation die seit
wochen weltweit für entsetzen sorgt und
die hölle auf erden gewesen sein muss
die ukrainische regierung meldet heute
dieser teil der humanitären operation
ist abgeschlossen was die menschen
erlebt haben oft unter der erde in
kellern und bunkern wochen lang ohne
tageslicht das wird erst jetzt stück für
stück klar und auch die geschichten
aller anderen auf der flucht aus den
unmittelbaren kriegsgebieten nehmen kein
ende
archiv die großstadt 20 kilometer von
der russischen grenze entfernt war
selbst heftig umkämpft jetzt ist sie ein
ort an dem die menschen zumindest mal
kurz aufatmen können michael haselrieder
und arndt ginzel berichten
ein park in haag if nach über zwei
monaten krieg kehrt ein wenig leben
zurück in die stadt an der front
doch für entwarnung ist es noch zu früh
vor drei tagen erst ist hier ein
geschoss eingeschlagen
gott sei dank war das in der nacht
niemand war da es war ja sperrstunde zu
friedenszeiten haben die leute hier auch
nachts gespielt das licht brennt immer
die sperrstunde hat den menschen das
leben gerettet
wir besuchen eine unterkunft für
ukrainische flüchtlinge aus den
kampfgebieten aller ist zum ersten mal
wieder beim friseur zwei monate hat sie
im keller gelebt während draußen bomben
fielen
wir hatten kaum etwas zu essen brot gab
es zwei monate nicht
natalia ist erst vor ein paar tagen aus
ihrem dorf geflohen das von den russen
besetzt war sie zeigt uns ein video
neben unserem haus ist eine bombe
eingeschlagen nur 10 bis 15 meter
entfernt wir waren gerade im keller da
haben wir beschlossen zu fliegen die
häuser haben gebrannt alles hat gebrannt
auch viele kinder sind den angriffen
entkommen sie malen um ihre erfahrungen
zu verarbeiten erzählen uns von
russischen soldaten
es sind sehr schlechte menschen das sind
männer die schießen
sie kommen in die häuser und nehmen die
männer mit sie schießen auf menschen zu
schießen mit panzern auf die häuser sie
schießen auch auf autos
draußen berichten uns die frauen
russische kämpfer hätten es auf junge
ukrainische männer abgesehen
sie haben einem jungen einen sack über
den kopf gezogen dann haben sie an ihm
vorbei geschossen um angst zu machen die
patrone haben sie ihm gegeben und gesagt
behalte die zur erinnerung sonst töten
wir dich
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht doch
viele der frauen bezeugen übereinstimmt
dass männer verschleppt worden sein
sie haben ihre hände und füße mit
klebeband gefesselt von vielen jungs die
sie nach russland über die grenze
gebracht haben wissen wir nicht wo sie
sind niemand weiß ob sie noch leben
die frauen und ihre kinder sind weg von
der front doch in sicherheit sind sie
nicht auch in prag if wird noch gekämpft
die weiteren nachrichtenlage an diesem
samstagabend hanna hast du jetzt im
blick christian und da schauen wir als
erstes auf die spd die seit dem
russischen angriffskrieg ja immer wieder
für ihre russland politik der
vergangenheit kritisiert wurde jetzt hat
spd-chef klingbeil angekündigt dass
seine partei die grundsätze ihrer außen-
und sicherheitspolitik neu bestimmen
wird der welt am sonntag sagte klingbeil
dass sich die spd zu stark auf russland
konzentriert habe künftig müsse viel
stärker mit den osteuropäischen staaten
kooperiert werden
mit einem festakt in der iss der
französische präsident makro in seine
zweite amtszeit eingeführt worden bei
seiner antrittsrede im elysée-palast
sagte er sein ziel sei es französische
und europäische antworten auf die
herausforderungen des jahrhunderts zu
geben dabei sprach er ukraine krieg
corona pandemie und klimakrise an vor
knapp zwei wochen hatte sich makro bei
einer stichwahl gegen die
rechtspopulisten le pen durchgesetzt
juni finden in frankreich
parlamentswahlen statt
die radikal-islamischen taliban haben
die rechte von frauen in afghanistan
weiter deutlich eingeschränkt laut einer
neuen anordnung sollen sie in zukunft in
der öffentlichkeit eine burka tragen das
gesicht müsse bedeckt sein um
provokationen bei begegnungen mit
fremden männern zu vermeiden bei der
erneuten machtübernahme haben die
taliban immer strengere vorschriften für
afghanen erlassen dürfen mädchen zum
beispiel keine weiterführenden schulen
mehr besuchen
nach der heftigen explosion gestern an
einem luxushotel in der kubanischen
hauptstadt havanna ist die zahl der
toten auf mindestens 26 gestiegen
mehr als 60 menschen sollen verletzt
worden sein laut regierung handelte es
sich um einen unfall bei dem ein gastank
explodiert sei in dem hotel befanden
sich zum zeitpunkt der explosion
angestellte aber keine gäste da
renovierungsarbeiten stattfanden
und jetzt einschnitt in der sendung
zurück nach deutschland
schalke ist zurück in der bundesliga
der aufstieg geschafft mit einem sieg
heute abend gegen st pauli
das klingt jetzt sehr sehr sehr dürr und
nachrichtlich und beschreibt natürlich
nicht mal annähernd das was jetzt gerade
los ist in gelsenkirchen
das ist pavillons in gelsenkirchen
die arena ein tollhaus
es war eine großartige aufholjagd nach 0
2 rückstand am ende ein 3 2-sieg
schalke 04 wieder in der bundesliga 3
182 tage
nach dem abstieg
und alexander ruda ist für uns live in
gelsenkirchen genannt alexander wo diese
nacht gerade erst begonnen hat oder
das kann man so sagen christian ich hab
mir auch ein guter standen also es gab
wirklich große emotionen in königsblau
am schluss hilfe stehen hier im
epizentrum der schalke fans in
gelsenkirchen buer nur einen steinwurf
vom stadion entfernt ist jetzt ein
bisschen ruhiger als noch beim
schlusspfiff aber da war natürlich die
emotionen sehr groß 3 2 gegen st pauli
schalke kehrt zurück in die bundesliga
gut zu 217 minuten das war nicht ihr
match plan vorgesehen beim public
viewing aber dann kam hat diese zweite
halbzeit mit dem königsblauen happy elm
sodann war er wirklich einiges los
scheitert von den letzten neun partien
erst mal geworden es war eine
beeindruckende leistung des ipads also
nur ein jahr nach dem abstieg in die
zweite liga dorthin wo sie nach ihrem
eigenen königsblauen selbstverständnis
auch hingehört nämlich in die fußball
bundesliga
[Musik]
ich finde das läuft schon ganz gut
alexander ganz herzlichen dank nach
gelsenkirchen und mehr dazu natürlich
auch gleich nach uns hier im zdf im
aktuellen sportstudio
wenn es um eine wirklich belastbare
datenbasis geht ist deutschland
merkwürdigerweise auch nach mehr als
zwei jahren corona immer noch
entwicklungsland nicht mal die frage wer
genau wo wie geimpft ist lässt sich
wirklich exakt beantworten bei uns ganz
anders als in anderen europäischen
ländern während also die
gesundheitspolitik immer wieder im
dunkeln tappt haben sich andernorts im
laufe der pandemie abermillionen daten
angesammelt in restaurants in
schwimmbädern beim friseur zum beispiel
das muss nicht nur stoppen da muss jetzt
auch kräftig gelöscht werden sagen die
datenschützer
es werden regten berichtet
die spuren der pandemie an den hamburger
landungsbrücken sind sie fast verblichen
vieles scheint weit weg vergessen server
aber vergessen nie etwas in zwei jahren
pandemie haben sich millionen von check
ins und aus und registrierungen
angesammelt persönliche daten die nach
14 tagen gelöscht sein müssten 41
millionen nutzerdaten hat die
betreiberfirma der low carb jetzt in den
digitalen mülleimer geworfen kontakt
nach verfolgungs datenreste die daten
waren wäre eine pandemie zweckgebunden
und daher dürfen wir die auch gar nix
anderes einsetzen wie für die
nachverfolgung von corona aber sie
können wir auch gar nicht für was
anderes einsetzen weil sie so
verschlüsselt sind die schlüssel liegen
nur auf den smartphones der bürgerinnen
und bürger daher haben wir den datenmüll
der bei uns noch übrig geblieben ist
davon jetzt auch vollständig gelöscht
die lukb
betreiberwechseln ihr geschäftsmodell
digitale speisekarte und bezahlt dienst
die pandemie als türöffner für neue
märkte aber um welchen preis
datenschützer sehen trotz aller aufräumt
versprechen den datenschutz um jahre
zurückgeworfen
mein gefühl ist dass der datenschutz
doch sehr gelitten hat in der pandemie
weil bürger doch viel offener und
vielleicht sogar mit ihren daten umgehen
und die wirklich jedermann zur verfügung
stellen und hier würde ich mir ein neues
bewusstsein nach der pandemie wünschen
zu mehr datenschutz
beispiel arbeitsplatz in der pandemie
durfte an der personalakte hängen was
vorher strikt verboten war
gesundheitsdaten atteste in zusammenhang
mit masken pflicht befreiung oder
impfstatus eine durchlebte gobiet
erkrankung vielleicht mit folgen alters
im schredder landen und aus den köpfen
verschwinden müsste
ein unfreundlicher arbeitgeber könnte
die nutzen können sie in die
personalakte eintragen könnte bei
späteren beförderungen oder
zuständigkeit entscheidungen unbewusst
oder bewusst diese
gesundheitsinformation verwenden auf dem
smartphone ist aufräumen einfacher auf
den ersten blick denn app weg heißt
nicht daten weg erst das endgültige
löschen des accounts dahinter macht den
datenschutz komplett wichtig übrigens
auch ohne pandemie und frühling
weil dort überall daten sind die
natürlich auch von den unternehmen
weiter genutzt werden können aber
vielleicht auch von cyberkriminellen und
dann vielleicht zu identitätsdiebstahl
oder zu anderen nachteilen für den
bürger genutzt werden und das ist
gefährlich
als computer noch nur computer waren war
das mit dem frühjahrsputz einfacher
festplatte raus und kreissäge an
vielleicht übertrieben aber in jedem
fall endgültig
und jetzt die lottozahlen an diesem
samstag die lauten 5 14 26 34 35 43
superzahl 2 alle angaben wie immer ohne
gewähr
der blick auf die wetteraussichten
südlich der donau bleiben morgen die
wolken meist dicht und es kann schauer
und gewitter geben ansonsten scheint
meist die sonne über den bergen in der
mitte bilden sich zum nachmittag
allerdings quellwolken aus denen es
gewittrige schauer geben kann die
temperatur steigt auf werte von 14 bis
24 grad am montag scheint dann überall
die sonne ab dienstag werden die wolken
im norden mehr und es kann auch mal
regnen vor allem im süden werden
sommerliche temperaturen bis 28 grad
erreicht
28 grad mit diesen wirklich schönen
aussichten sagen wir danke für heute
morgen sind wir wieder für sie da und
zwar sehr gerne und wir wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]